hey yo what's going on it's your boy
China Mac check me out on the bootleg
Kev podcast let's get it
bootleg cat podcast special guest in
here my guy
China Mac yes sir welcome thank you
first of all I want to say
congratulations to you sir because
you've it's been about a year and some
change year and a half since you've been
here yeah and I feel like since then I
mean you've always had a huge presence
on YouTube and like uh but like I feel
like your growth as a personality has
been is insane hmm Mac eats is on fire
let's go Mac talk you know what I'm
saying twitch right that's the that's
the other channel okay that's the
channel
because you were also doing like uh
weren't you also doing like um
interviews yeah yeah yeah I'm doing it
now that's the back talk okay you're
right yeah yeah but but hold up
congratulations to you though well thank
you man you know what I mean I've been
seeing you no I've been seeing you
leveling up like you know what I'm
saying like uh congratulations to you
and your new club yeah man we got 11 11.
new studio this is probably the last
interview anyone will watch in the
studio China mag makes makes the exit
you feel me it's only right yeah
um but yeah dude it's been dope to see
dude because I always felt like that was
one thing when people would watch you on
Vlad
you know I feel like your your
personality would shine through and
people were so into you I mean you also
are an amazing rapper right but I feel
like people just kind of
um they took a liking to like just who
you are as a dude you know what I'm
saying so for you to be able to go
around and like tour different areas and
eat the food and like dude it's better
than any of the [__] food shows that
I took your [__] no I mean like if
you're not like food shows on Netflix
here but your [__] is lit it's a little
different I put a little spin on it like
how would like okay obviously you're
always gonna try to evolve and improve
the show but at what point in time do
you feel like you got to a place where
the show felt like fully like oh no this
is like things are different now when I
started going to the hoods and the food
like everybody does
like you know go to the popping
restaurants oh look this restaurant is
so cool but like when I started going
into people houses and they cooking out
the house and selling meals out the hot
like that I was like okay I'm wanting
something yeah I mean like because
people ain't gonna do that people ain't
gonna go into the middle of watts and
like you know I mean go to a house and
eat waffles with cereal on it or go in
Stockton in the middle of nowhere and
they cooking and crabs and stuff how was
Stockton Stockton's a pretty active
Place yeah Stockton is like yeah it's
definitely is active you know I mean I
had to be very it was kind of quiet but
it's one of those quiet that you know is
like is it get crazy you know what I'm
saying so for where all have you gone so
far like like in terms of just like
where's the craziest place you've gone
or the most random Place Stockton's kind
of random shout out to Stockton yeah
Stockton shout out to Stockton I'm at
the Texas
uh Houston Dallas or I I mean I'm going
to Houston shout out to akiway I'm about
to go with them I'm about to go Aggie
way to Houston but no I went to some
I don't even remember the name of the
town bro it was just like some random
spot that I did I did a uh I did a
challenge like a steak challenge day or
something oh so it was like a restaurant
where they had like a famous yes I
pulled up over there and then like you
know but um I've been to uh Cambridge
Boston uh I've been to
um a bunch of places bro that I'd be
forgetting but yeah what's been the uh
worst Food you've eaten on on Macy's Wow
Wow just be honest
um Filipino food bro really yeah was
that in Stockton no that was right here
Kazumi brought me to the spot shout out
to her she's a she's a yeah she's a
professional yeah she is you like her I
mean I mean not yet
I mean
she may or may not have popped up on a
friend of mine's Reddit feed not mine
yeah right
yo but um
yes she brought me to like eat some
Filipino food like some traditional not
traditional did you do the baby duck egg
thing yo that was you did that I did
that oh yeah that's what that's what
yeah that [__] is [__] shout out to my
Philip I mean everyone around me in my
life is Filipino is it are they my
manager's Filipino my producer for my
radio Show's Filipino most of my fight I
got so many Filipino shout out to the
Philippines that like uh yeah it's just
you know I mean it's like a half yeah
half developed baby right you see some
of the egg but then you see some of the
the is like halfway developed
and you ate that
you know yeah it was gross it was Grosso
yeah it was it was just
it was just yeah it wasn't it wasn't my
thing yo what do you think about like
what like as somebody who I feel like
you're a great representative of your
culture and making sure whenever there's
any sort of uh
just like [__] going on whether it's
racism or just [__] going on in the news
like let me ask you this
on Tick Tock at least five or six times
a day I get a swipe and I see a little
asian lady eating some wild ill [__]
right like I will say your people have
the highest tolerance of just eating
[__]
yeah is that a safe assumption they eat
some crazy stuff man but that's like
like the baby duck thing is just crazy
baby duck is crazy but then I also seen
some stuff like it was like a snail or
something she was smacking it and then
like the only thing I've had this
Filipino is the uh the little egg rolls
what are they called right E40's got a a
um he's part owner of a company that
does them
but they're like they're just like egg
rolls yeah yeah yeah that's all the
Filipino food I've had those are dope
yeah I can't [__] with them yeah they
have developed embryo yeah and then like
you know I mean
yeah I can't rock with a lot of that
food I'll try it you know just for the
sake of trying but I'm for the sake of
content yeah after the sake of content
you know I mean I would try it anyway
even without the content just to say you
know because it's culture and you know
what I'm saying but I'm not really you
know what is your okay how long have you
been in LA full time it's been about a
year I've been out here for like
I moved out here like five months ago
okay so you've been out here five months
give me your favorite restaurant in La
that you've had that reminds you because
I feel like New York has some of the
best restaurants I think specifically
some of the best Asian food that I've
ever had is in New York City right have
you have you found a place here that
reminds you of some food back home or
that is just kind of like your go-to yet
it's different the Chinese the Asian
food here is different and I miss New
York food I ain't gonna lie I miss New
York food
um but the Asian food let's talk about
the Asian food the Asian food is
different than New York first of all
y'all in La don't have the the staple
like Chinese Hood spot I don't I ain't
see it like maybe they got them but I
know for sure I probably just ain't
going the right neighborhood but you
know in New York every block you got a
staple Chinese Hood spot you know what
I'm saying chicken wings fried rice with
the Duck Sauce you know what I'm saying
out here
I I don't you know I mean I don't think
yeah they don't really do that out here
like that I miss that you know I mean uh
oh
they they have better like hot pot and
like real Chinese like Chinese food
Chinese food in terms of like you know
out here out here they have better like
like real Chinese food but they're like
corn you know it's funny because we were
in Canarsie with the dusty Locane and
shout out to Dusty man and he freeze
Dusty he did he took us straight to the
the Chinese spot and I think I had like
a
did you have the chicken wings frog yeah
the chocolate like they chopped up the
chicken wings yeah yeah and then it was
with the fried rice yeah the Duck Sauce
that's exactly that's that's like when
you said that that's right that's
literally what I ate yeah a little soy
sauce soy sauce for the rice duck sauce
on it no duck sauce on the rice you know
what I'm saying soy sauce on the chicken
and the rice oh my God yeah it was a
great spot it was like it looked like
it's a playset like they don't do that
out here yeah yeah yeah for sure yeah I
mean somewhere but I mean yeah but like
you know so I know I know the area
you're staying in a lot of stuff over
there is like nice yeah yeah yeah yeah
they got they got they got nice stuff
but I'll be traveling all around
throughout L.A but I just don't see that
but then you know they got better Asian
food when it comes to like real Asian
food like you know what I'm saying hot
pot and stuff like that yeah like the
food is there's more Asian people here
well you know what I fell in love with
in La is uh
OC to get the [__] I I there's a spot
there did you go to the place that's in
the like kind of like in that mall
there's like a mall of just food in the
orange yeah yes
insane yeah oh my God what yo the fall
here is amazing bro the fun New York I
would never eat the food and the and the
ramen man the ramen is crazy yeah come
on LA's got great food man I ate some
spicy I did a spicy Ramen challenge
yesterday [__] my [__] I was [__]
Peppers oh no yeah [__] that's right uh
well hey I gotta say man um I'm glad
you're here because I mean you obviously
there was a huge what are we talking
about man there was a huge tragedy that
happened in Monterey Park yo bro I was
there I know that's why I said I'm glad
you're here physically because you you
were there I was shaking I was shaking
bro that I I mean I would when I say I
was there I wasn't there like it didn't
happen like right there in front of me
but I was eating at a restaurant like
right next to that Ballroom on Garvey
and whatever right uh so whatever
Ballroom I didn't even know it was a
ballroom I was eating at the restaurant
right there we got out of that
restaurant at like 10 15. 10 15 we paid
everything I walked out the door at like
10 15. we got to about 10 15 10 18 I got
to my car the shot started going off at
like 10 20 25 that's when the first
police report went on went on you know
what I'm saying and I was out there and
I didn't know I was driving to another
party I was driving to a party and then
when we got to the party the girl I was
with was like yo do you see this we were
just we were just here we just left it
and I was like what I went in a party
for like maybe 10 minutes out and she
she was so freaked out that she wanted
to leave right and she so we left we got
back I went home and I'm just like
like minutes and and you know what I'm
saying like I felt like I escaped look
because
I didn't know it was in a ballroom so at
the time I thought he was just like
shooting in the street right so I felt
like I escaped that but then I also know
if that's going on you're gonna go up in
there and try to
no I mean if if it's inside I'm not
gonna run in there but he was If he if
he's in the street right shooting
I'ma react bro like like you know I'm
saying like I'm gonna react my life and
I'm not gonna allow anybody to just like
[__] right do whatever like I'm gonna
be on the news too I'm gonna be on the
news right along with him but if it's
like inside somewhere I'm not running up
there and like doing all that but if
it's in the vicinity like say I'm in
Walmart and somebody is doing that and
I'm you know what I'm saying I have the
uh you know the capabilities of reacting
I'm gonna react right because I don't
know if you're gonna turn around and
shoot me or if you're gonna shoot a kid
or whatever so you know
um I I felt like I escaped that bro I
ain't gonna lie and and God Rest
God bless those people man and then
there was another one yesterday in San
Francisco right right in the Bay Area
yeah in the Bay Area there was another
one another [__] Chinese dude
shoot up a bunch of Chinese dudes I
don't know what the hell is going on I
don't know what this is but it sounds
fishy to me man it sounds interesting
it's just that
it's like it's like a sick coincidence
because this no no the story is like the
one in Monterey Park he the story is do
you know are you familiar with I'm not
sure like I I saw the video of the guy
getting taken down and then obviously
the guy killed himself in the white van
in Torrance but I'm not sure like I
don't know anything he went from
Monterey Park he shot that up he got in
this call he left he drove to Alhambra
which is another heavily Asian another
heavily Asian community
and he went into another spot so that
what I've read was that he went to the
first spot because his ex-girlfriend or
whatever was in the party and he wasn't
invited to some some crazy stuff like
that right and then he shot it up then
he left and he went to Alhambra to shoot
up another spot but that doesn't make
sense to me because like if you wasn't
invited to one party and you shot it up
why are you going to another spot you
wasn't invited there either like what
the hell they're also very far apart
right they're also very far apart so now
he goes in there but he get he he
wrestles The the one of the young people
that was at the door wrestles him for
the gun you see it it's on video he's
he's taking a gun from him he's taking
the gun the guy he's just crazy shout
out to that guy yeah shout out to him
whoever he is and he tries to like fight
he tried to wrestle the gun out of him
he had an opportunity to shoot the man
too I would have I would have smoked a
dude you would have smoked it if I'd
have took the gun from him and he's
still trying I'm getting you in the leg
at least I gotta put you down first
right right like yeah he's better than
me he's better than the dude was trying
to pick up a water bottle and yeah yeah
that shit's crazy bro so you were like
[__] dude like you said if you like what
if you were like sitting there and you
saw a guy walking in with that gun you'd
be like what the [__] like you you don't
know how you're going to react in that
situation
bro I mean I know how I'm gonna react
yeah I'm saying I ain't gonna say how
I'm gonna react but I will react with
like no that [__] [__] up bro that's
why that's why you know what I'm saying
I went on my I went on my YouTube
channel and I made a video immediately
and you know people were saying oh you
trying to profit or like get clout over
that incident but no absolutely not
that's not what the [__] I was trying to
do right what I was trying to do was
make a video and say hey everybody
Whoever has the ability to get your gun
license go get that [__] like
you know I'm saying everybody should
have their gun license if you can have
it you know what I'm saying it's only of
your sound yeah California they make it
a lot harder
um but but you can still make it happen
but they've made it easier since the
pandemic yeah you could still make it
happen so that's what I'm saying like I
went on my YouTube channel to tell
people yo go get your gun license
because you never know what now like the
world is so crazy you could be walking
in Walmart somewhere shopping with your
kids and here come this crazy
[__] shooting up you know what
I'm saying and you know you got to
protect yourself and protect your family
by all means so I went on my channel and
tell my people go get your [__] yeah go
get your gun license try you know what I
mean
hey we gotta stop the interview to tell
you about our folks at my bookie that's
right baby Super Bowl is coming well you
know in a month or so we got the
playoffs right now you could get those
future bets in on who you think out of
this uh barrage of teams that made it to
the playoffs is going to win the Super
Bowl you could bet player props we can
go NBA action on them so much ways to
make money with all the sports going on
and you could do it all at my bookie
right now if you go to my bookie and you
sign up for a new account use the promo
code bootleg and they will match your
first deposit up to a thousand dollars
you know what's dub about my bookie not
only can you bet on your favorite sports
but you could also get a little
Blackjack going little slot machines in
that thing yummy a little loud little
roulette yeah me so much ways to get
paid on my bookie the most important
thing is though if you sign up
and you use the promo code bootleg at my
bookie go to my bookie my bookie my
bookie my bookie use the promo code
bootleg and they're gonna match your
first deposit up to one thousand dollars
right [__] now
listen I'm a degenerate but I'm pretty
good at this
I've been using my bookie for like 10
years all right very trusted they're the
best trust me they are the [__] best
wherever you're at if you're watching
this you can sign up for my bookie
account one more time that's my book you
use the promo code bootleg and they will
double your first deposit up to a
thousand dollars free [__] money
let's get to it all right boys back to
the interview you have had a pretty
successful independent rap career yeah I
spoke with ad about this a few weeks ago
and he was essentially saying like man
this personality [__] I've made like 10
times more than I've ever made sex is
are you in that same boat um super in
that boat yeah I was in that boat before
him but yeah yeah but definitely yeah I
found that's why I started doing the Mac
eats and that's why I started that's why
I fully kind of just went that lane
because it just takes too much as a rap
artist you gotta put too much money you
gotta do you gotta invest all of the all
of that into it and you're not sure if
you're gonna you know I'm saying you're
gonna get any money back and then you
might not get any money back for a few
years also and if you do then you have
to sign a deal I mean you probably gotta
sign a deal and everybody's got their
hands in your pocket you know what I'm
saying versus this this you don't really
need to do [__] you just get a computer
and and you know what I look at too is
like I feel like
you guys like you guys like ad who like
have like
like fans you guys like [__]
successful artists independently but
like that music almost was like um
a an investment into getting people
interested into who you are right which
makes it able which makes you able to go
on Vlad and make sure able to go it and
now be your own you know your own
YouTube yeah so it's just growing it's
just the growth and just being able to
reinvent your selfie for me and I think
that's like as you know that's that's a
trait that is necessary for survival in
this game but any in life in life yeah
you got to be able to reinvent yourself
I'm curious you go on Vlad often would
you say a few times a year yeah I
haven't been on Vlad for a minute but
were you ever a part of his like paying
regular guest program yeah so you would
get a bag for each interview yeah I
always get a bag over there nice yeah
shout out to Vlad man yeah shout out to
Vlad man I don't know I mean that's like
if it works right I mean because I think
a lot of people probably give him like a
a bad rep but to me it's like I don't
know many other platforms that like
monetarily cut you in on but he said
that since he started doing that his
[__] exploded even more he made even
more money well because if it's working
right you know like with boozy right
yeah every boozy interview like goes
crazy come on and he clips that [__] a
million times Eclipse it crazy he's the
he started that he's the clip God he's
the cliff God shout out to shout out to
Vlad no he's the reason why we clip art
him and Joe Rogan the reason we clip our
[__] right it makes sense I think who
did it first vladder Joe Rogan I think
Vlad did for sure no I think Vlad did
that for sure yeah Vlad started doing it
he he everybody was like at first when I
saw that I was I didn't understand like
I mean but you know once I started
looking at the numbers you put your
stuff I mean for my uh for your
interviews for my interviews yeah yeah
yeah I mean yeah you still a new way
yeah yeah shout out to laugh for that
man so when you're like uh okay so what
is your I'm curious just from like being
on this side of things when you hit the
road yeah you decide to do a Mac eats
right yeah what does your team look like
how many people are hitting the road
with you how many cameramen do you got
like what is your like setup like what
is your kind of like your your school it
depends where I'm going you know I mean
um it depends where I'm going but
usually bro I'll go with my cameraman
and I go with myself and maybe one homie
and you know what I'm saying and and
whatever else we need one camera every
time
One camera every time that's what I do
one camera's great yeah getting some
great [__] any if you guys ever fly
drones
I mean uh we have yeah we have a few
episodes yeah sure yeah what it's like
for you is the goal to eventually
because I I think YouTube is the new TVs
when people are like oh I'm gonna make
it on TV I don't give a [__] right yeah
nobody cares about you no one gives a
[__] it's like nobody cares about radio
yeah respectfully as someone who's on
the radio in 18 cities no one gives a
[__]
um but um
for you what is like the because we've
seen Action Bronson do this kind of
first right with [__] that's delicious
and he's turned that into
restaurants and food trucks and books
and right all that like for you what do
you want to take Mac eats in terms of
like you know how like how do you want
to scale this thing man
I mean all that like I'm gonna do a
restaurant you know what I'm saying do
some sauces you know what I mean the
sauces will go crazy sauces you know I
mean do different stuff like you know I
mean the sky's the limit honestly like
you know I don't know I might I might do
whatever but have you had any offers to
do any TV stuff yet with TV stuff yeah
like I'm sure I have yeah yeah but I
just you know turned it down yeah I'm
not really
you know what I'm saying like like you
said the TV stuff is like you know we
making money on this like if it's not if
it's not going to be like a super big
situation or if it's not going to be a
super big bag then why would I you know
I mean like I think I I I'm waiting for
the best for the right thing to come
along yeah I feel like for you it would
make sense if it was like a prestigious
like Netflix situation right like
something like that because even
something that's really going to put me
it'll it'll raise your profile and it'll
raise your funds in every other capacity
right you know what I mean right so uh
okay so you just put up a video today
about um was it today about Math Hoffa
yeah I mean yeah well I saw I so I I
don't really all I saw was I think last
week
he had posted your guys's DMS was that
the case am I on this I mean and then he
pretty much was like Hey guys if I don't
hit you back you know whatever whatever
but he happened to use your DMs as an
example right
um and then I mean there was more to it
but
um I mean it's all over the internet I
don't want to keep on talking about him
and being a dead horse right but I will
say this well you posted a video today
no it was yesterday okay it was
yesterday okay I posted a video but he
me and him went live okay okay so after
that live I'm like you know what I'm
saying I don't want to keep on going on
a whole tour about it right right but I
will say this
I will say this
um
I was fooled
you know what I mean okay you got it I
was fooled I I didn't know that he was
acting this whole time I didn't know
that he had a costume on because that's
basically what he said on the live
because I was like oh you a street dude
you know what I'm saying and he was I
was like yo Street dudes ain't supposed
to have a uh somebody with a somebody on
a show talking about an active murder
case you know what I'm saying so um no
Street dude would do that and he was I'm
not a street dude okay you know what I'm
saying and and and and so when I met him
I met him a while ago you know I mean
and I was just under the assumption that
we came from the same cloth and came
from the same like more rules and and
and you know what I'm saying the
principles like you know what I'm saying
so now now he showed himself yesterday
on the live he said that's not what he
he's not from that and that's not what
he rep like that's not he he he that's
not what it is but when I first met him
that's what it was that's what he said
he was right so you know I my bad I
didn't know that you that he had had a
costume on and a lot of people is see
you know what it is people do things and
they carry certain they carry certain uh
uh uh morals and principles when it's
convenient for them you understand what
I'm saying and now since it's not really
that convenient they just take it off
and they just you know and also
hey we got to stop the interview real
quick to tell you about our family at
hard Dean that's right Hardin Las Vegas
the craziest dispensary in the world the
number one dispensary in the United
States let alone in Las Vegas all right
maybe you're hitting Vegas with your
friends your girlfriends whatever maybe
it's a bachelor party whatever's going
on you're going to go watch the Raiders
suck [__] whatever it is make sure you
pull up to Hardy in Las Vegas tell them
I sent you they got the craziest
selection of Premium cannabis I've ever
seen in my [__] life the pre-rolls
the cartridges the Edibles the flower
all top-notch all the best the bud
tenders are so friendly it smells great
it smells so good inside a Jardine
that they have their own Harding
signature scent candle
see I sniffed that and I just think of
Las Vegas and picking up some amazing
weed all right so go follow them right
now Harding underscore Las Vegas shoot
him a follow get all the details you
need you can get you some of this fly
ass Harding merch at hardinglasvegas.com
shout out to our family in Vegas I'm
excited too because coming up we're
going to be doing our very first podcast
from Jardin in Vegas with young gravy oh
yeah it's going down all right let's get
back to the interview I'd like to point
out this YSL thing has really shown that
people aren't keeping the same energy
with certain artists right
what do you mean by that I mean right
let's say the Gunner situation yeah
right
um I'm not too privy to like all of the
details of that situation so I don't
really want to dive into it too much but
I think that uh like six nine obviously
was an unlikable guy right I think a lot
of people were rooting against him
because he was kind of a dick when he
was popping yeah people really didn't
like him right he talks a lot of [__]
he's a dick whatever but
he snitched fair enough and got
blacklisted from
playlists and [__] now fans can the
marketplace is the marketplace but you
know certain there are certain industry
things that you can be blacklisted from
that can sort of affect or hinder maybe
your numbers in a certain way right and
I just don't think that that's going to
happen with gonna and I'm not saying
that they're the same
at all but it just feels like
a lot of people are kind of waiting and
seeing yeah but I mean here's the thing
that situation is not done yet so you
don't know like it's not like he took
the stand or anything so you know but
how look at Boston Richie
I just saw 1090 Jake put out uh hold on
but look at Boston Richie like they took
look at what future did Future took all
of his tour he took him off the tour but
not only that he took off all the songs
that he was on he didn't he he's not on
no features on the Boston Richie album
you know what I'm saying so it has to
have some weight because it's still you
know I mean it still affected his Boston
Richie was coming up he was big you know
I mean well he just signed with uh he
just signed a record deal like last week
but that was wait with a major uh I
think
Atlantic signed him was that before no
it was after the initial allegations
came out
and now there's this new video that came
out today uh I think it's gonna
regardless I think it's gonna affect his
his it has affected his career it has to
because like you said he's one of the
hottest right so so regardless of what
people might say you know it's still
affecting you know what I'm saying it's
still I just think gun is like kind of
like a pop star I don't know I think if
it comes up I think if there's a video
of him taking a stand and stuff so it's
gonna be different yeah you know I mean
so so yeah I don't know that's that six
Nine's way that's his what he's saying
but it's definitely affecting people you
know what I'm saying it's affecting him
and it's going to affect anybody else
it's probably not affecting to the way
that it would have back in the day but
it's still taking a toll like it's still
you could just go look on uh Boston
Richie's Instagram it's just different
now yeah I'm saying like it affects he
was on fire he was on fire you know what
I'm saying so you know but what I'm
saying is it's like people you know
um they they like like like uh uh uh
just people just like funk that's the
flex you know what I'm saying he made a
post saying oh I'm gonna play six nine
music but he's the first he's the same
person before that was like you know
upholding a certain standard whatever we
don't [__] with rats and he would go on
talking about it or whatever whatever
but now it's changing now people are
just taking it because now it wasn't
it's not convenient anymore before it
was convenient before it was like then
the street people ran this and we have
to like you know what I'm saying so
everybody just conformed with it because
it was just like okay that's the way to
go that's the wave you know what I'm
saying but now that the wave now people
can eat without doing that they're not
conforming to it so it's fine like a
person like see like fun Master Flex I
don't look at him like a street dude but
I just see okay so why did you even
conform to it in the first place why did
you even you know jack it in the first
place but now whatever it's nothing
nothing but a person like the one the
person that you just said before uh uh
uh he he's different you know what I'm
saying he's a person that was punching
people
yeah yeah he's like he's like shooting
at entourages he said he done Rob people
he's like it's different from that you
know what I'm saying so
you're gonna look at him I expected
something different and I shook his hand
before like he's somebody I know he came
up to me he when I was locked up he said
free China Mac free the real ones he
came and shook my hand was like um was
like oh you a real one you know what I'm
saying we gotta stick together you know
what I mean so it was a little different
you know what I'm saying that makes
sense people was like oh why don't you
call out Vlad why don't you call out
uh uh uh no jumper why don't you call
that academics first of all none of
those people come from the street so I
don't expect them to to do anything
their platform and they have a different
platform different set of codes right
right so I don't I don't expect that
right he's like oh they Noriega had them
on well I I don't [__] with that even
now you know what I'm saying like I mean
I already got a who won norviega had
Troy Ave on top about whatever but what
I'm saying is like I just you know I
mean it ain't personal it ain't like um
but it was just some I don't know
Noriega I never shook his hand he never
said anything to me he never looked me
in my eyes and we never had a
conversation you know what I'm saying uh
uh but this person did like we had a
conversation he's you know what I'm
saying like he shook my hand and said
you're a real one we're a real one uh uh
so all of that so I I he tried to like
the the the the DMS was like you know he
tried to say that that's the reason but
that's not the reason like you know what
I'm saying like I don't I don't care if
you don't do my show or if you don't do
anything like I'm saying that's not that
wasn't my thing you know what I'm saying
but you know what it is is he tried to
flip it like not just him but people
everybody like a lot of people trying to
flip this race car thing right A lot of
people are trying to say that I'm a
visitor to hip-hop you know what I'm
saying and I don't have a right to speak
on certain things all right anybody
that's saying that you got it you got it
look I'm gonna take my glasses off you
got it you won you won
you won I'm a visitor to Hip Hop I'm a
visitor to Hip Hop so I'ma pack my [__]
and go respectfully all right but before
I pack my [__] and go I'm gonna take
some things with me that belong to
my my culture right okay so uh Nas Nas
Illmatic nice Illmatic right five mics
yeah yeah Miss info gave him those five
mics Miss info is a korean-american
woman Miss info gave him those five mics
I want those five mics back respectfully
so now
Illmatic ain't a classic no more
okay we're not gonna stop there I got
some other things I want to pack up with
me when I go all right
um
Pharrell Neptunes Neptunes Chad half of
chat half half half right here he's
happy yeah right right I need all of
that back too and half half like divorce
divorce half I need half of that right
so uh Snoop Dogg Beautiful
I just watch it enough I needs that I
need half of that you know what I'm
saying Super Thug I need half of that
too you know what I mean I'm taking all
that with me too you know what I'm
saying oh I'm not done I'm not done
Wu-Tang Clan Ain't Nothing to [__] with
I need that too that name I need that
too Wu-Tang Clan we need that too
respectfully you know what I'm saying
into the 36 Chambers we need that too
respectfully you know what I'm saying uh
uh uh mystery of Chess boxing
need that too
there it is
I think that uh the people who leave
those comments though the visitor [__]
it's like it's so low it's like low
hanging fruit
to me the ray like Ray [__] and Hip-Hop
like I get sometimes like the
low-hanging fruit is like when someone
calls me a culture vulture
like after I don't have them on my show
or they've DM me 10 times and I'm like
I'm just not into it you know you're a
[__] culture vulture I'm like I mean
all right dude you know like
does that make you feel better
you know yeah it says come on it's just
is is it is is is
that's weak man going with a race car
this week you know what I'm saying like
I understand like I understand that
people is like okay hip-hop is a black
culture and I'm not I'm not taking that
from the black people hip-hop is a Black
Culture but let me tip before but but
hip-hop was what
hip-hop was made in New York [__]
City
New York City the Bronx hip-hop is a New
York culture before you say any of that
hip-hop is a New York culture because we
the ones New York was was the first ones
to do hip-hop it formulated in in New
York City the Bronx the Bronx the boogie
down it came from the Bronx right you
understand what I'm saying and I don't
know where you from if you ever been to
New York but New York is like this like
everything is on it's not like La where
everything is where the Asian people are
here black people were here Mexican
people here no New York is like these
people here right here right here you're
building your top of this building
everybody is on top of each other right
so if anything when hip-hop was was was
was made
everybody in a vicinity was around it
just five elements to hip-hop I bet you
all those people leaving comments on my
page soak them out I'm a visit to Hip
Hop y'all can't even name the five
elements to hip-hop this is true you can
you wasn't even alive when I started
listening to Hip Hop I started listening
to hip-hop in
1987. you were still in your daddy nuts
in 1987 coming on on my page talking
about I'm a visitor but what the [__] is
you talking about if I'm a visitor to
Hip Hop that logic that you have because
hip-hop was made by black people right
and um hip-hop was made by black people
let me calm down a little bit hip-hop
was made by black people okay
me being an Asian-American man born and
raised in New York City around hip hop
since I was a kid 1987 was the first
year I was introduced to hip-hop right
if I'm a visited hip-hop being that I
was born and raised and I learned so
much in hip-hop and Hip-Hop was a part
of my life the only thing that's been a
part of my life for all those years of
my life right the only thing that I
still have something to do with is that
still that's still a part of my [__]
daily right if I'm a visit to Hip Hop
solely because I'm not black
then if we adopt that logic Michael
Jordan is a visitor to basketball
white people invented basketball
so I mean
you telling me Michael Jordan is a
visitor to basketball LeBron James a
visitor basketball Muhammad Ali float
like a butterfly thing like a bee I'll
visit a boxing
the nerve
imagine a white person come out and say
man you guys playing basketball are
visitors to basketball it would be an
absolutely absurd thing if someone said
that for sure that'd be a ridiculous wow
but but
people be so I don't know what people be
thinking bro people would just be caught
up in their own thing they don't think
with logic let's think with logic we are
not in when I'm not from China I'm not
from Africa I mean I'm not from China
hip-hop was made not in Africa hip-hop
was made in New York city in America so
yes it was started by black people but
it's everybody in that vicinity was
affected by it immediately it spread
like it spread like a disease like it
was all over it was hip-hop was it
wasn't just black people listening to
hip-hop bro there's five elements to it
there was spent there was Puerto Ricans
doing doing break dancing there was
people doing graffiti Asian people doing
graffiti and it was also it was it was
all types of stuff going on so um
respectfully uh
shut the [__] up
well there you have it by the way some
of the best DJs ever are all Asian like
[__] man Qbert
Qbert is that guy DJ craze yeah there's
some great some great Asian DJs out
there and and for people to try to paint
the narrative that I'm like
racist like bro I don't have our races
bone in my body bro like I came with
somebody today you know I'm saying
everybody I'm constantly with black
people like you know I'm saying like I
don't have races I don't have those
Tendencies but I'm not gonna stand down
on [__] nobody's gonna strip me of what
I feel like is mine you know what I'm
saying so I'm not gonna allow that no
time nobody I'm not gonna do that that's
like me letting you take something from
me I die before I let you take something
from me facts we gonna shoot it out
before you take something from me facts
so that's what we gonna do I'm not
backing down bro never
um
is there any of the new [__] that you
[__] with though as a hip-hop fan like
are you like on some fan [__] is there
any of the new [__] that you're like
listening to like on your own I like
that pz song um
that's just hard it's just that old
school yeah
oh oh oh wait who made that original
joint the original yeah yo bro that just
brings me somewhere else bro that that
that that what wasn't that it's uh is is
Dennis Edwards Don't Look Any Further
yeah
I'm saying and Peezy the way he took
that sample and you could hear you can
still hear this lyrics like the song in
there you can hear it in the background
it's still going and he's just going
over it with this nonchalant flow like I
love that you know I mean like I think
he killed that like you know what I'm
saying yeah
um I saw like a A.D talking that he
might do some like celebrity boxing [__]
and who he says that we're down to fight
somebody yeah I'm down who are you who
are you gonna fight
um we suppose I'm supposed to fight Nina
boy okay I don't see I'm not tapped into
the universe enough to know who that is
right he he's he's somebody from La okay
I'm saying uh uh you know and um we
supposed to get it I mean you know
listen I I know I talk a lot of [__]
everybody wants to see if I could back
it up right you feel me so why not let
why not give the people what they want
let's see if I could really do my thing
let's see if my hands move like my my
mouth pause hey yo but yeah but uh but
why not let's get in that ring you know
what I'm saying like like so we trying
to set it up right now we in the process
of setting it up you know what I'm
saying and um and yeah I I mean you know
well speaking of I mean obviously one of
I think one of the moments where people
kind of got to really kind of see
your
like ability to kind of carry a
conversation or it was when you and Jen
squash your guys's beef on YouTube right
um happy New Year man legendary YouTube
uh moment legendary rap moment uh how
often do you talk do you guys talk ever
yeah I mean I speak to him once in a
while what's up you know I mean happy
holidays [__] like that for me what is
he doing I don't know he got family he's
he's uh breastfeeding I don't know what
he's doing
hopefully his wife
you never know equal rights equals
everybody yeah
Jesus Christ oh
man yeah we're gonna clip this one up
nicely here we're gonna clip this one up
nicely yeah
oh China Mac all right well um okay so
you got Mack eats you got Mac talks
um you have your new twitch show yeah
the twitch [__] is kind of like uh it's
it's like a it's like his own thing man
like
um it's like like yeah I'm I'm doing
like kind of following like how I
started doing that was A.D called me and
he's like yo bro you gotta do this you
got to do this like I'm saying you're
gonna kill it like boom he told me that
like a while ago and that it took me a
while to like yeah because just recently
you bought everything yeah just recently
I'm saying and then I don't know if you
know who sneako is you know who sneako
is yeah he he him him and A.D both
actually sneako told me first you know
what I'm saying that's when he started
blowing up on that [__] right and then
and then I kind of was just like I was
in New York I was in the process of
moving and stuff and then A.D tell me he
kept on telling me and I was just seeing
his growth and I'm like I it's time for
me yeah how's it been so far man oh man
it's been all right like it's you know
it's a growth is I'm growing but I could
just you know when you start something
and you can see that you can see it
right away it's not like it's gonna go
crazy off that but I could see like you
know I'm gonna have I'm gonna make my
mark over there yeah you know what I'm
saying is it have you been I know it's
like is it a certain amount of time it
takes to become a twitch partner
um uh yeah you got to do like certain
things you got to do like uh you gotta
have like you know um you gotta go live
uh I'll us like 80 hours or something
like that something like seven times
chicks on there just doing twitch from
uh hot tubs and [__] oh you've seen her
too yeah you watch her no I don't I do
I just I just saw uh one of those what's
one of the famous guys uh the speed guy
yeah he was like saying that he wants
that [__] to get banned wow and I was
like wait they got [__] and Hot Tubs
on Twitch yeah what the [__] is going on
it's lit it's great yeah I'm sure
there's better live sites if you're into
chicks and hot tubs yeah yeah I mean
there's some webcam farming like name a
country yo I gotta ask you a question
hmm
bro what's up with this Bluetooth [__]
man what's up with you bro so if you go
to Bluetooth
and he used the promo codes yeah you use
that [__] I've used it
yeah it works it works oh it gets your
[__] crazy you use it all the time not
all the time you have a dependency on it
no no they're a great partner on the
podcast
so I'd like to point out that it works
great right and you don't even have to
go see a doctor
if you just go to bluetooth.com you use
the promo code bootleg they're going to
send dick pills right to your door
they're going to send a chewable form I
I'm not supposed to use the words pill
they're gonna send dick chewables
to your door and discrete Packaging
wow so
same ingredient as Viagra and Cialis so
your [__] will be rocked up bruh I
didn't I didn't know you was that was
going to be a segue for a commercial
I was just asking you like well now I
now I
hey we gotta stop the interview to tell
you about our family at odd sucks that's
right the most comfortable socks in the
[__] world go to
oddsocksofficial.com right now use that
promo code bootleg and you'll save 20
off Christmas time is it coming and let
me tell you something their Black Friday
sale if you're watching this before
Black Friday you might be watching it
after Black Friday but if Black Friday
hasn't came yet just like Cyrus hasn't
came yet it's been a while he's on a
drought guess what oddsoxofficial.com
promo code bootleg 20 off plus whatever
the [__] else is going on with their
Black Friday sale and let me tell you
they got some new licenses we got to
talk about boys
my particular favorites
one of the greatest shows of all time
they got the Beavis and butt heads you
know what I mean and this is really a
big deal
The Big Lebowski that's right the
greatest movie to ever exist
and shout out to all you rappers and
people who'll be pouring your lean into
this [__] some Mountain Dew Baja
Blast socks
Casino great [__] movie you know what
I mean these are pretty fly Bubblicious
yeah that's right a little Bubblicious
and this is the big one
big deal here
we got Coca-Cola socks baby that's right
Coke's on board
Coke is on board yeah I mean we get to
put the coke hat on
this hat doesn't work for me does it
doesn't work for me anyway you could get
you this hat though hey Cyrus take a
Coke hat there you go go to
oddsoxofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg right now save 20 off and go
purge their website for Black Friday get
gifts for your family your [__]
family will love you if you buy them the
most comfortable socks in the world it's
that simple or you could buy them some
[__] [__] socks you could go buy
him some garbage ass [__] ethica or
some [__] ass [__] Nike socks
[__] them get Odd Socks let's get back
to the interview all right so now that
you guys uh got that Bluetooth engine
out the way
much love uh China Mac music coming soon
yeah we got music I got a working on you
know a movie goes to Chinatown oh about
you yeah oh who's playing you you I
don't know no it's it's about like the
childhood segment of my life okay so
like it's gonna be like maybe from like
14 to like 18. are you gonna have like
uh essentially because because I from
what I understand it's kind of getting a
record deal right like you maybe
developed a pilot get the script and
then you try to shop it around right now
it's already it's already uh oh it's
already it's already you already got the
record deal for it yeah nice yeah that's
big it's a nice very good deal too shout
out to them shout out to the labels
uh I'm trying to think if there's
anything else we need to talk about man
your music the YouTube channel is doing
great man I just see you keep evolving
and keep looking yeah listen China Mac
TV make sure y'all sign on to that
subscribe I also have my streaming
platform Mac talk and that's Mac talk on
YouTube and Mac talk on
um what's the other twitch twitch yeah
twitch twitch go watch my guy appreciate
you pulling up bro I appreciate you guys
yo this is the last one we signing off
it's over let's get it